يعني في راي الدراسات هناك عده حلول بسيطه
من شانها ان تخفف من مخاطر الجلوس لفترات
طويله او ما يسمى التدخين الجديد اهمها
التحرك كل نصف ساعه للتحفيز على ذلك ينصح
بضبط المنبه للتذكير بالمشيكل 30 دقيقه
ايضا من المهم القيام باي تمرين لرجلين
والذراعين اذ يمكن ان يساعد ذلك في بقاء
الجسم مفروضا ومرنا ويسمح بضخ الدم اثناء
الجلوس ولا تنسى تناول وجبه واحده على
الاقل يوميا وانت واقف وانجاز بعض المهام
اثناء المشي مثلا خلال تصفح الانترنت
وغيرها وانت واقف يمكنك القيام بخدعه
بسيطه عبر شرب الكثير من المياه بذلك تكون
الفائده مضاعفه فبالاضافه الى اهميه
المياه للجسم والتحرك للشرب سيدفعك ذلك
ايضا للتحرك والتوجه الى الحمام كثيرا
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات